this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business
check out Squarespace through the link
in the description below more on them in
a bit in the 6th century bc cyrus ii of
persia embarks on a mission of conquest
Kingdom after Kingdom fell before him as
he forms the our community Empire the
largest empire the world had ever seen
up until that point it kept growing
under successes like cam by seasoned
darius until it to felons the might of
Alexander the Great
during the late fourth century BC Cyrus
left behind a rich legacy but one which
is still filled with uncertainties
mythologies and misapprehensions he has
a reputation not only as a conqueror but
also as an innovative administrator and
a pioneer of human rights how much of
that is deserved well we'll trying to
find out today as we look into the life
of Cyrus the Great King
[Music]
Cyrus ii was born about 600 BC in Antrim
an ancient city ruled by his father King
came by seized the first his mother was
man Dane a daughter of Ostia gaze king
of the median Empire Greek historian
Herodotus gives us a very detailed and
dramatic accounts of Cyrus's childhood
however it leans heavily on the
mythological side but then again so do
most sources that deal with Cyrus
according to Herodotus the marriage
between can by cease amending occurred
after Steve's had a prophetic dream
where water flowed from his daughter's
womb and flooded his kingdom he
consulted with his major who concluded
that his dream was a foreboding vision
that meant the downfall of his empire as
shoegaze wanted to place his daughter
somewhere safe ins out of the way that's
why he married her to come by seize a
persian who ruled over a small and weak
city which would surely pose no threats
to his kingdom soon afterwards the
median King had another treatment
this time vine sprouted out of his
daughters whim covering the kingdom
osteo gaze and his major they took this
to mean that manda is offering was the
one who would prove to be his downfall
the conclusion was simple the child must
die when Cyrus is born as to gaze gave
him to one of his most trusted servants
at maiden name topic Asst the king
commanded him to take the child home
kill him and bury him instead he gave
the baby to a cowherd named mitrik
Dottie's and ordered him to do the evil
deed by leaving the child in the most
desolate part of the mountains Metro
Darcys agreed but also couldn't bring
himself to do it it just happened that
his own wife had been pregnant and just
given birth to a stillborn child they
decided to pull the old switcheroo and
left their son in the mountains and
raised Cyrus as their own the boy was
not called Cyrus during this time and
while Herodotus does not mention his
name
Strabo gives us Tazz Agra Dottie's Cyrus
lived as the son of a cowherd for ten
years until he was found out one day he
was playing with other children in his
village he was proclaimed king and gave
out orders which one of the other boys
refused to obey to address this insult
the King had the other boy beaten his
father a noble maiden named art embarras
complained to the real king because our
timbers was an important courtier our
sega's himself once you talk to the son
of a cowherd and
soon realized his true identity
subsequently he got the real story out
of Madrid Artie's and later Hargis Syrus
got off easy
upon renewed consultation with his major
as our states concluded that since Cyrus
was made king by the boys of his village
his prophetic dream had been fulfilled
and therefore the child was no longer a
threat he was still of Persian blood
though so he was sent to live with his
birth parents in Anjan the one who truly
felt the wrath of us to our gaze was
Hargis the minion who disobeyed the
Kings order Howard Lee our steer gaze
showed no ill will towards Parga sand
even invite him to feast in honor of his
newly discovered grandson there he
tricked his servant into eating his own
son who had been killed dismembered
boiled and roasted before the banquet
austere gaze revealed his malevolence
act by presenting Hargis with his son's
head hands and feet after he had
finished eating publicly Hipparchus
reacted calmly simply saying that
whatever his King did pleased him he
collected his son's remains buried them
at home and began plotting his revenge
in 559 BC cyrus ascended to the throne
of ansion like his predecessor he had to
acknowledge the authority of the median
Empire and pay tribute unannounced king
of steer gaze the Hipparchus began
courting the new king and encouraged him
to get the Persians to rebel against a
stare gaze promising that he would get
the matey's to do the same Cyrus was on
board with the plan but he needed a way
to unite the Persians back then Persia
consisted of multiple tribes and he
required all of their strength to stand
against the kingdom of media Cyrus's
tribe was the posaga day but Herodotus
also identified the Marathi the mass be
the Darus ia the pan oh my I have no
idea a whole bunch of different tribes
with weird names that I can't pronounce
Cyrus summoned their representatives to
him and told each to bring a sickle on
the first day put them to work and he
had them clear and prepare a stretch of
land up to 20 furlongs long in each
direction on the second day he had them
wash and take part in a sumptuous feast
in the meadow where wine and food were
plentiful afterwards he simply passed
them which day they preferred and
obviously everyone answered the second
date that is when Cyrus promised those
who stood by him only days like that
free of toil and slavery while those who
opposed him would have Labor's
unnumbered most Persians resented having
to submit to the Maties in the first
place so Cyrus's proposition was not
exactly a hard sell even so we do not
know if all the tribes joined in on the
revolts but there were enough for Cyrus
to go to war against the median Empire
in a moment of pure foolishness
osteo gaze assigned pious a commander of
his army we don't know if he forgot what
he did to his son or if he genuinely
believed that his general had forgiven
him for it either way Hipparchus
definitely remembered and waited
patiently to exact his vengeance he kept
his end of the bargain with Cyrus and
convinced many Metis to betray our
staircase therefore or as the median
army marched many soldiers deserted
while others openly joined the Persians
those who remains loyal to the old king
were defeated in battle not left with
much choice the steerer gaze assembled
another army from the men left in baton
of the kingdom Capitol and let himself
and Cyrus the new force mostly consisted
of youths and sold men and they too
rebelled against the king and Surin
osteo gaze over to Cyrus this happens in
550 BC according to the Nibbana descry
Cole and Cyrus the Great and to
triumphantly into a katana the Persian
King spared us to gaze and kept him
round his court until his death cyrus
also married one of the median kings
daughters a meatus which helped
strengthen his legitimacy as a ruler and
pacify him the median vassals it was the
first step in assembling the Achaemenid
Empire
[Music]
you might be wondering why a Persian
Empire founded by Cyrus was called the
economic Empire it's worth taking a
little time to explore his lineage and
try to present it as best we understand
it the dynasty is named after akin amis
the epical ancestor from which all of
the first rulers of the first Persian
Empire to send it whether or not he
actually existed though is still a
matter of some debate the main source we
have for his existence is the best an
inscription a giant rock relief carved
into mount bear stand in the Zagros
Mountains commissioned by King Darius
the great the inscription tells of his
own rise to power scholars are
fascinated by the best inscription
because it was vital in helping them
understand cuneiform script as the
inscription was written in three
different languages Old Persian elamite
and Babylonian in that regards this
monument is similar to the rosetta stone
which helps us to decipher hieroglyphics
to us it is relevant because in the
first section darius traces his lineage
all the way back to our chemin ease
according to the family tree presented
in the inscription Archimedes founded
the dynasty and was succeeded by his son
hey space there is some corroborating
existence not only that tasties existed
but that he captured the city of anshun
and became king here is where the family
tree branches in two directions taste
bees had two sons Cyrus the first grand
father of Cyrus the Great and area
Romney's great-grandfather of Darius
when Darius became King he married two
of Cyrus's daughters and later his
granddaughter thus merging the branches
once again so it is possible that the
lineage is that straightforward but
here's the problem that many scholars
have with this notion
Cyrus himself makes almost no mention of
Archimedes in the Cyrus cylinder which
we talk about a bit later
Cyrus identifies himself as a son of CAM
by seize Ranson of Cyrus and descendant
of ty Spees there is no mention of
Achilles the only reference is an
inscription on a column at the ruins of
palace P in Pasig ad which says I am
Cyrus the king and Ark emanate this
could have been added later and some
archaeologists indeed believed that this
is the case they are pine it was the
work of Darius who wanted to strengthen
his claim to the throne and establish
continuity with the previous Kings who
until him had always been direct
descendents of the previous rulers now
there is a bit of good news
gonna be any confusion on that sort of
stuff these days because we're excellent
at sharing information and a great way
to do that is online which brings me to
today's fantastic sponsor Squarespace
and that was quite the transition and I
want to tell you about Squarespace
before we get into the rest of today's
video two simple things one maybe you've
got an idea for a website or a business
a YouTube channel something like that
going around in youhow do you think
maybe better go
that could be a good thing to do and -
well the only way to figure out if
that's actually a good idea that people
want is to get it out into the world and
I can be daunting because it's always
scary to go out and try new things but
not knowing how to set up a website and
tell people about that idea should not
be an excuse and you can get around that
excuse with Squarespace
Squarespace allows you to create a
powerful website that will allow you to
do well whatever you want you want to
sell something online do it with
Squarespace start a podcast do it with
Squarespace you've got a youtube channel
well obviously you host the videos on
YouTube but you need a companion website
for that do it on Squarespace
it all starts on Squarespace with a
beautiful template that you can
customize to your heart's content or
start from scratch if you've got design
skills I've said it before
I definitely don't just start with a
template it's a lot easier don't make
excuses for yourself and once you gone
through the super easy customization
process of that template there's no
updates there's no patches there's no
tech BS to deal with no one likes any of
that stuff and Squarespace also handle
all the website e staff a podcast like I
say absolutely mailing their social
media integrations all of that stuff and
much more plus 24/7 support for if you
get stuck which is incredible
Squarespace comm gets you a free trial
and when you're ready to launch just go
to Squarespace com forward slash buyer
graphics and you're gonna save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain it also supports the show which
is wonderful and let's go back to Cyrus
[Music]
Syrus had conquered the kingdom of media
and brought it as well as its vassals
under his commands unsurprisingly not
everyone was okay with his conquests
specifically he earned the ire of King
Croesus of Lydia who was the
brother-in-law of Esther geez
Croesus was famous for his vast wealth
and even today you might have people
described as being richer than Croesus
you might also known for his ill-fated
counsel from the Oracle of Delphi
he sent the priestesses their priceless
gifts such as statues and vessels made
of gold and asked them if he should send
an army against Cyrus the Oracle also
known as Pythia replied if Croesus goes
to war he will destroy a great Empire
never did it occur to him that it might
be his own
so the Lydians crossed the Halys River
into Cappadocia and captured the city
Metiria this most likely occurred in 547
BC Cyrus mustered his own army and
marched to regain his lands the two
sides met in battle and fought a
stalemate with both sustaining heavy
casualties strategically it was a
victory for the Persians and Croesus
fell back to the Lydian capital of
Sardis his plan was to wait out the
winter and in spring attack again with a
launcher ami which included his allies
such as the Egyptians the Babylonians
and the Spartans who literally Croesus
disbanded his remaining soldiers
thinking that Cyrus would never march on
Sardis with winter fast approaching
but the Persian king did just that Cyrus
knew that his best rata victory would be
a quick assault before Croesus gathered
reinforcements the two armies fought
again in December at the Battle of thin
bro Cyrus scored a decisive victory
according to Herodotus the winning
strategy came courtesy of Hipparchus the
Lydians had a large and powerful cavalry
to count to that are Fergus advised
Cyrus to put his frontline soldiers on
the dromedary camels that they brought
along to carry food in cargo his
reasoning or is that horses were afraid
of camels and even hated their smell
Lance would turn to flee when they met
indeed this was the case and many Lydian
soldiers were thrown off their mounts
and quickly dispatched by the Persian
infantry running behind the camels most
of the Lydian army surrendered what was
left of creases as forces retreated to
Sardis but of course
Cyrus followed closely and laid siege
creases hoped that his allies might
still come and save the day if he could
hold out
my last seizure lasted only 14 days the
Persians entered Sardis by scaling a
section of the wall that was completely
unguarded the grounds outside was so
steep that they were thought to be
unclaimed Abal but a soldier named Jairo
''tis proved that it was possible and
the rest of the Persians quickly
followed suit and so sadhus fell and
with it the kingdom of Lydia which after
six hundred and fifty years became a
province of the art Kinnaman empire the
fate of Croesus is a question that
remains unanswered today according to
Herodotus Cyrus intended to burn him on
a pyre but the god Apollo's and
arraigned put out the flames seeing that
the former Lydian king had divine
protection Cyrus allowed him to stay on
as one of his courtiers as he did with
the staircase of course this is a rather
fanciful tale where the once mighty King
gets a happy ending the birds about
hilla Diaz said that Croesus wanted to
burn himself alive but that Apollo took
pity on him and sends him with
Hyperborean 'he's a mythical race of
giants in the land of the north scholars
have interpreted this as a poetic way of
saying that the king had a peaceful
death the last piece of evidence which
suggests that Croesus indeed died during
the fall of Sardis is the nabonidus
Chronicle once again it states that in
the year 547 or 546 BC during the month
of Adjara which corresponds to a prolong
may Cyrus marched against a country
killed its king and took its possessions
the only problem is that the inscription
is partially damaged and we can't make
out the name of the country it could
have been Lydia or it could have been
someplace else
[Music]
siress continued as conquering ways and
captured many cities in Asia Minor in
Mesopotamia and so this continued until
there was only one other power left in
all of Western Asia the neo-babylonian
empire ruled by King Nibbana de souza
core we've used and will continue to use
as a main source unsurprisingly war
erupted between the two nations but
unfortunately while we know the major
points we have very little detail on the
war the only large-scale battle that we
know of took place at AAPIs in 539 BC
and it was a decisive victory for the
Persians days later they took the city
of spar which surrendered without any
bloodshed interestingly enough multiple
sources indicate that Cyrus walked into
Babylon itself without battle and here
we arrive at another contentious point
the cyrus cylinder for instance portrays
the Persian king as a liberator who was
welcomed with open arms by the
Babylonians this is not completely out
of the question as neva notice might
have been an unpopular king who angered
his people by ignoring the Marduk the
patron god of Babylon and trying to
enact a religious reform based around
the worship of the moon god sin then a
Bala does Chronicle also says that the
army of Cyrus ended Babylon without
battle but does not provide us with any
juicy details this could mean that the
people were happy with their new king
but it could also fall in line with
differing ancient accounts which say
that the two armies simply fought
outside the capital however it happens
the outcome was the same mighty babylon
had fallen and was now part of the
economic Empire never to be an
independent power again
[Music]
now Cyrus was king of the four corners
of the world a title meant to denote a
person who ruled over the whole of
Mesopotamia however he was faced with a
new problem
how would he oversee and manage the
largest empire the world's never known
obviously he couldn't be everywhere at
once but his kingdom would be full of
issues which demanded his attention from
serious problems like riots uprisings
and food shortages to mundane affairs
like taxes and military recruitment
Cyrus employed a primitive version of a
federal government he divided his empire
into administrative units known as
satrapies which were run by governors
called satraps 26 satraps were appointed
in Cyrus's time and they ruled in his
name dealing with all the issues that
might arise in their regions they had a
lot of authority but Cyrus had the
forethought not to give them too much
unchecked power there were still
officials who were outside the purview
of the satraps and they reported
straight to the king they included army
generals finance officials as well as a
special courtier who went from one
satrapy to another to conduct
inspections known as the eye of the king
truth be told this was a strategy that
Cyrus borrowed from median Empire they
used client Kings who acted like
governors over smaller autonomous areas
but Cyrus was the first to employ them
on a really large scale this innovative
approached the administration of a large
empire proved successful
even as Cyrus's successors continued his
expansionist ways to add new kingdoms to
their lands a testament to this was the
fact that the Empire lasted for another
200 years after Cyrus's death until it
was conquered by Alexander the Great by
comparison Alexander's Empire
immediately collapsed and splintered
after he was gone
[Music]
perhaps another factor which helped
stabilize the economy Empire with
Cyrus's alleged policy of tolerance
there are multiple historical and
religious texts which assert that Syrus
allowed the people he conquered to
practice their own customs and religions
he endeared himself to the Babylonians
by taking part in their New Year's
celebrations and obtaining the blessing
of the god Marduk in the Bible it says
that he allowed the exiled Babylonian
Jews to return to their lands
consequently he is referred to as
Anointed of God one artifact that was
greatly responsible for Cyrus's
reputation as a liberator and champion
of human rights as the cyrus cylinder
recovered from the ruins of Babylon it
now sits in the British Museum and is
often hailed as the first charter on
human rights in the world
this view is chiefly promoted in 1971 by
Mohammad Reza Pahlavi the last char vir
on the idea was continued by the United
Nations but it is one that historians
and scholars are not really happy with
they see the cylinder as a priceless
artifact but one that is filled with
standard propaganda basically it
portrays Nevada says an unjust ruler and
shows Cyrus as the liberator chosen by
Marduk to come and save the Babylonians
it is in line with Mesopotamian
traditions and should not be regarded as
anything more than a political
declaration
[Music]
the death of Cyrus ends with one big
question mark as there are at least five
different outcomes
according to ancient sources although
some assert that the king died
peacefully at home most agree that Cyrus
Meadows ends in battle against whom
exactly a last bit of a bone of
contention Herodotus again gives one of
the most detailed accounts although even
he admits that he had multiple stories
and this is simply the one that he
deemed most worthy of credit in 530 BC
Cyrus fought the massive Goethe
animatics alien tribe ruled by queen
Thomas Cyrus first extended an offer of
marriage the Queen which she refused
although another source presented Thomas
as the wife of Cyrus either way the two
armies were supposed to meet an open
battle but Cyrus set a trap for the
troops and killed many of them including
a general who happened to be the son of
the Queen angered by this deception
Thomas gathered all of our remaining
forces and met the Persians in a fierce
battle where she emerged triumphant most
of the Persians have been slain Cyrus
included ending his reign of 29 years
not satisfied Thomas tracked down his
body decapitated in then dipped Cyrus's
head in the pool of blood so that the
King might fill his bloodlust which cost
onerous the death of her son
the remains of Syrus were interned in
mausoleum in the capital of pasig AD
named after his tribe the ruins of this
ancient city still exists Dane the city
of Shiraz in modern-day Iran and the
most treasured landmark today is the
tomb of Cyrus
oddly enough the tomb might not have
actually been around today if it were
not for the greatest enemy of the
Arcanum at Empire Alexander the Great he
was an admirer of Cyrus Greek historian
re and related how the macedonian king
paid a visit to Cyrus's tomb after
conquering his empire he was deeply
angered to discovered that thieves had
desecrated it and stolen almost
everything of value the golden lid on
top of Cyrus his coffin was gone his
body had been thrown to the floor
perhaps in a failed attempt to steal the
entire coffin which proved too heavy
Alexander ordered the tomb repaired and
Cyrus's remains restored to their proper
place he also had the guards of the
monument arrested and tortured so they
would give him the names of the thieves
also there was an inscription which does
not exist anymore so the exact wording
is a very fee it said o man I am Cyrus
son of camp Isis who founded the Empire
of Persia and ruled over Asia do not
grudge me my monument so I really hope
you found that video interesting if you
did please do hit that thumbs up button
below and do not forget to subscribe we
got brand new videos just like this
currently four times a week so please do
hit that subscribe button hit the
notification bell see if funding down
when we put out a new video also why not
check out another channel I do called
Geographics if this channel is about
people that one is about places it's
linked to below and as always thank you
for watching